we do have some pretty big news stories
today but before we get started I have a
very horrible and sad announcement to
make and it it breaks my heart to say
this earlier today Roberto Jr suffered a
heart attack and he died instantly and
we're all very sad Roberto Jr for those
that are familiar is the rooster that we
we uh Brad and raised he was only just
over two years old and we were kind of
shocked by we knew that he may have been
a little sick we weren't entirely sure
if anything was completely wrong with
him but he had been acting a little bit
more docile lately and he was having his
feet cleaned
and he just had a heart attack and died
we attempted to perform I could do not
chicken CPR we have uh oxygen we tried
giving him oxygen nothing worked there
seemed to be nothing we can do and uh
we're all very heartbroken to uh to have
to tell you everybody because as you
know we had a 95 foot tall billboard of
Roberto Jr in Times Square he is the
mascot for our coffee brand